I like to have a specific smell I don't
like to chop and change my scents some
guys have like a day scent and an
evening scent but I just really love
this I feel like it's a bit me I've had
people say that they were on the bus or
something and and someone was wearing
this and they thought oh Simon's on the
bus but I think they might be
discontinuing it which is which is a
tragedy I'll have to get a new smell and
then no one will know who I am I'm
terrified young Greg Tarzan Davis who is
a new addition to the Mission Impossible
cast plays agent dagar at the premiere
of Mission Impossible in New York we had
a what I can only describe as a scent
Collision he was wearing a beautiful
Armani suit I saw him I needed to touch
him we embraced and our scents combined
in the air into some super scent that a
lot of people around men and women
became spontaneously aroused